[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
françois henry des érables pour son
roman mon maître et mon vainqueur l'un
des meilleurs romans de cette rentrée
littéraire peut être même le meilleur
olivier normand le leader de musique
post bourgeoise qui sera nouvel ep et
sera en concert gratuit jeudi à 23h au
bain à paris n'hésitez pas n'importe
quelle musique c'est la bande originale
de notre époque et pascal jacob qui
publie clown un beau livre sur
l'histoire des clowns depuis leur
origine et l'on commence tout de suite
par les images que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque on va
regarder tout de suite la vôtre pascal
jacob alors dites moi de quoi il s'agit
alors c'est une photographie de
sebastiao salgado qui est un
représentant un camp de réfugiés au
rwanda donc c'est une image qui
n'atteint petit peu mais je pense que
c'est une question qui nous préoccupe et
surtout cette image qui est à la fois
terrifiante et en même temps se dit
qu'il ya une voie peut-être il ya un
ailleurs et que ça me reflète bien cet
autre désir d'aller vers un monde
meilleur votre image avoue olivier your
man
c'est une modélisation des commentaires
et des lacs des sur des réseaux sociaux
et sont des scientifiques français qui
font ça donc le rouge et le bleu chasse
sont des choix mais ils partent de
l'idée qui sont commentées et en fait il
ya des interactions
ils vont ceux qui sont contre une idée
vont les choper des éléments et à partir
de ce moment là les attirer dans leur
camp et on voi en effet la modélisation
le camp rouge c'est ceux qui sont contre
le comble évidemment ça ça c'est ça
c'est de la psychologie cognitive mais
on voit qu'en fait ça ressemblait les
combats spatiaux mais ce que je veux
dire parce que pourquoi est-ce que ses
contemporains c'est que moi je me tenais
que des gens passent leur temps à liker
des instagram venu pourquoi est ce qu on
fait ça en fait ça te donne ça et je
pense que l'homme se numérise puisque
dans sa journée il aura finalement plus
grande incidence dont la l'information à
travers ça que parce qu'il va raconter à
son voisin mais ce qui est frappant
aussi c'est qu'en fait il parle très peu
entre eux en fait alors on parle entre
gens qui sont contre et entre gens qui
sont brouillés mais ça suffit à aller
chercher l'information elle a ramené de
l'autre côté pour la pour la détruire
et vous forcez misérable votre image
alors moi c'est une photo de robert
mapplethorpe
que j'ai vu lors d'une exposition à rome
j'ai pris cette photo en photo je les
poster sur instagram et instagram a
voulu fermer mon compte la censure est
donc géré posté cette photo simplement
en dissimulant les tétons de la delà de
la jeune femme rien ne montre pas c'est
bien passé et c'est passé mais ça manque
quand même tout ce puritanisme
absolument ridicule de
de la société américaine et notamment de
7 et des réseaux sociaux et je me suis
dit que l'américaine parce qu'en fait
ils croient suivre un standard
international sur bien sûr mais bon qui
essaie d'imprimer pas mal de la montrer
dans une émission qui s'appelle il est
interdit d'interdire c'est moi qui suis
bonne introduction à votre roman dont on
va parler tout de suite
[Musique]
françois-henri des érables votre nouveau
roman non mais très bon vainqueur paru
aux éditions gallimard vient de
remporter le grand prix de l'académie
française d'une valeur de 10000 euros
que comptez-vous faire de cet argent
jules renard disait que le métier des
lettres est le seul où l'on puisse sans
ridicule ne pas gagner d'argent à la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
quand on en gagne écoutez ça fait
longtemps que j'ai envie de prendre le
transsibérien donc peut-être que je vais
m'offrir un voyage en train entre moscou
et vladivostok
ça va vous paraître très très longue
peut-être mais moi aussi comme la clé
des victimes français je trouve que
c'est le meilleur roman de la rentrée en
tout cas c'est le mieux écrit c'est pour
ça que vous avez choisi un thème
rabâcher le mari la femme l'amant c'est
pour montrer à quel point c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet assez éculés et que le la
difficulté est justement de d'essayer de
renouveler un peu ce thème moi j'essaie
de le faire en imaginant qu'un homme qui
est tombé amoureux d'une femme tire sur
quelqu'un d'autre lors d'un mariage on
retrouve sur lui un revolver qui n'est
pas n'importe quel revolver puis celui
avec lequel verlaine a tiré sur un bo en
1873 et on retrouve également sur lui un
un cahier sur lequel il a écrit des
poèmes et au juge d'instruction qu'il
interroge et bien il répond vous n'avez
qu'à lire les poèmes tout est dans les
poèmes le juge les lignes il comprend
pas grand-chose convoque donc le
meilleur ami de cet homme qui est aussi
l'ami de la femme dont il s'est épris et
le son meilleur ami qui est le narrateur
va se faire l'exégète du recueil de
poèmes dénouer les fils de cette passion
amoureuse et aider le juge à résoudre
l'anc est donc tout le
le truc c'est en fait d'essayer de
déplacer un peu le curseur d'essayer de
renouveler un peu ce sujet là on en
adoptant un point de vue un peu
inattendu et qui n'avait pas été revu
puisque j'insère beaucoup de poèmes dans
ce livre c'est pourquoi vous l'avez
intitulé bon mais très bon vainqueur
amassé un titre magnifique d'abord la
première raison c'est pas de vous et
justement c'est pour ça que j'ai dit la
première raison c'est que milan kundera
s'est accaparé absolument tous les
meilleurs titres pour les romans d'amour
l'insoutenable légèreté de l'être
risibles amours la valse aux adieux
voilà des titres que j'aurais pu donner
que j'aurais aimé pouvoir donner à mon
livre et lorsque je l' ai commencé je
n'avais pas de titre et un jour je lis
un recueil de poèmes méconnu de paul
verlaine chanson pour elle et je lis un
verre
verlaine écrit études ou soudure est il
sensible aux moqueurs ton coeur je n'en
sais rien mais je rends grâce à la
nature d'avoir fait de ton coeur mon
maître et mon vainqueur et lorsque je
lis ça je me suis précipité sur google
pour voir si quelqu'un avait déjà pris
c'est vers là pour en faire le titre et
j'ai su d'emblée que j'allais mais c'est
vrai c'est pas le coeur de la jeune
femme qui est le maître et le vainqueur
c'est son corps dans votre roman c'est
son corps c'est son coeur oui c'est un
roman alors c'est aussi un moment il ya
des scènes de sexe
alors non justement je trouve que la
plupart des histoires d'amour qui sont
racontées en littérature sont parfois
assez pudibonde
aujourd'hui vous pensé au 21e ouais il
ya une certaine mièvrerie et je trouve
que les histoires d'amour passionnelle
et qui font justement l'économie de ces
scènes de sexe passe à côté de quelque
chose il faut dire qu'il ya une c'est
très difficile d'écrire une scène
la scène une scène d'amour
et on peut on peut très vite tomber dans
des dents des écueils que j'ai cherché à
éviter justement mais justement dans
votre roman on voit bien peut-être parce
qu'il ya un narrateur qui dét aucun donc
aucun des protagonistes
on voit bien au fond qu'on confond
aujourd'hui l'amour et le désir sexuel
les deux vont ensemble on confond aussi
l'amour et la passion amour c'est la
passion amoureuse à quelque chose de
très éphémère
liée au désir évidemment lié aussi qu'il
ya l'idée de douleurs dans la passion la
première acception de la passion c'est
celle du christ ce sont les souffrances
endurées par le christ le christ et la
passion existait avant la crise a fait
mais met donc il y a
la passion amoureuse vient avec tout son
cortège de maux de douleurs de troubles
qui ne sont pas forcément dans l'amour
le sexe oui je chauffe la pression on
est passé du mariage enfin en vous
lisant l impossible on est passé du
mariage arrangé autrefois la passion
sexuelle sans jamais au fond qu on
confondre ce que ça se confondent avec
l'amour au fond la planoise sens sexuel
à l'ours c'est ce qu'on a pour ses
enfants pour ces courses pour ses
parents pour ses amis éventuellement oui
alors vous savez moi j'ai lorsque
quelqu'un a parlé d'un sujet dont vous
voulez parler mieux que vous vous le
citez et moi je trouve que l'une des
plus belles définitions qui a été donné
de l'amour cl de bart nos fragments d'un
discours amoureux qui parle de
l'assomption démentiel de la dépendance
c'est-à-dire que vous assumez le fait
d'être
totalement à la merci d'une personne
sans laquelle vous perdez pied et bien
cette relation là
peut-être aussi sexuelle mais pas
forcément donc l'amour peut être dénué
de sexe mais en général la houle dites
dans votre livre tout cas le narrateur
le dit je crois il dit au fond cette
jeune femme ne vient pas combler un vide
en créer un elle vient créer un manque
mais est-ce que ce matelas n'est pas le
désir sexuel ou en tout cas le sexe plus
que l'amour puisque l'admiration qu'il
peut avoir pour elle je plains potion
qui l'a beaucoup d'admiration pour elle
il a juste de l'attirance une attirance
sexuelle réelle ouais pas théâtre ça
peut être ça mais
oui mais il ya aussi des couples
qui découple légitime ou la sexualité
était pas nous y est néanmoins
connaissent aussi des relations
adultères donc peut-être qu'on cherche
aussi autre chose et je crois qu'il a
mon personnage vasco a pour cet hymne à
une attirer ce qui n'est pas seulement
sexuelle qui est aussi
intellectuel il y a un lien véritable
échange elle a même été prise de poésie
elle adore paul verlaine lui et
conservateurs à la bnf d'ailleurs il va
essayer de la séduire en lui montrant là
la réserve délivrera requis et là où
sont conservés les plus grands trésors
de la bnf réserve que j'ai eu la chance
ou j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir pénétrer
c'est vraiment c'est une salle qui est
grande comme ce studio où il y as
absolument tous les plus grands trésors
de la bibliothèque celle de france la
bible de gutenberg les épreuves
corrigées des fleurs du mal
les poèmes manuscrits de victor hugo et
lui valait lui mettre sur la table un
après l'autre une tension érotique qui
va monte monte monte et un moment et
bien ils vont vouloir faire l'amour est
le seul endroit que faire l'amour c'est
la table sauf qu'il ya tous ces trésors
il perd pas les débarrasser cette table
d'un revers de main alors ils vont
devoir reposer chaque livre chaque
trésor à sa place puisque dans une
bibliothèque un livre qui est mal rangée
est un livre perdu après quoi ils vont
pouvoir se connaître un peu plus
bibliquement met donc ya pas seulement
ceux cet aspect sexuel de la chose je
trouve qu'il ya une vraie complicité
une histoire de coeur dans votre roman
puisqu'il va lui voler à la bnf
également mais l'autre celle que rue
richelieu il va lui volé le coeur de
voltaire ouais c'est vrai que le coeur
de voltaire et dans le socle de la
statue
que lui à sculpter ou dont validé raymor
1778 son coeur a été prélevé s'est
retrouvé entre les mains du marquis de
villèle qui était un de ses amis puis
les passer d'héritiers en héritier et à
la fin du 19e siècle on a un qui se
demande ce qui peut faire avec ce truc
qui décide de le léguer à la
bibliothèque qui est devenue la
bibliothèque nationale de france qui a
donc fait bâtir cette statue d'oudon
voix voltaire c'est une station qui est
assez amusant puisque c'est vraiment
voltaire vieillissant marquée par les
outrages du temps on voit qu'il est très
raide et amaigri j'ai pas mis en photo
pour pas de nangis jd et dans le socle
de cette statue la bibliothèque
nationale de france a décidé de placer
le coeur de voltaire qui se trouve dans
un dans un
un petit coffret il se trouve que moi
j'ai eu la chance donc de faire ce que
l'art et à la bnf appelle une résidence
j'ai été invité à
pouvoir me promener à ma guise dans tous
les endroits de la bnf et résidence au
terme de laquelle je devais faire ce
qu'on appelait une restitution c'est à
dire en tirer un texte que je devais
lire sur la grande scène de la bnf et je
me suis dit que j'allais essayer de
dérober le coeur de voltaire et faire
une restitution sens premier du terme et
donc un jour je suis arrivée avec des
affaires de piscine sous laquelle
j'avais dissimuler des outils moi je
suis en effet une famille de
quincailliers
gdc les sept plaques j'ai pris le coeur
je les ai eus pendant une semaine sur le
chambranle ma cheminée et puis je les
restituer solennellement lors de ma et
j'ai décidé de raconter ses histoires
d'un livre puisqu'à un moment mon
personnage vasco cherche un cadeau pour
l'anniversaire de tina et décide de
dérober le clan de voltaire de lui
remettre ses cd une tradition qui se
perd on ne garde plus le coeur des
grands écrivains ni leur cerveau des
meilleurs moments mais parfois on essaye
de les mettre au panthéon
et et aurier de léguer votre coeur de la
gamme car oui ou que ce soit d'ailleurs
à l'intérêt non moi je voudrais très dur
et demi en cendres une poignée de
cendres blême soluble dans le vent la
lagune à venise moi je jouais dispersé à
la punta della dogana oui j'ai
l'impression que voulait pour que vous
décrivez dans ce roman c'est l'amour
impossible
vous dit d'ailleurs qu'il paraît plus
grisant que l'amour conjugal au fond
elle est partagée entre deux choses
votre jeune femme par la bourre
conjointe entre l'amour conjugal et
l'amour impossible
oui et je fais une analogie avec le
comment le vert régulier qui est un peu
comme l'amour conjugal c'est à dire qui
est soumis à certaines contraintes à
certains impératifs alors pour le verre
régulier on doit respecter faire des
alexandrins si vous faites un saut n'est
fait faire de 80 suivie de deux percées
en alexandrins avec alternance des rimes
féminines et et alternance des masculine
et l'amour conjugal pareil il ya des
contraintes il y a des la pesanteur du
tête à tête quotidien par exemple qui
est une contrainte voilà d'accord avec
vous c'est plutôt l'amour extra
conjugales lui qui jouit de ses
contraintes parce que l'amour l'amour
conjugal n'a pas de contraintes au
contraire de l'amour extra conjugales
mais il est pour moi dépourvu de
contraintes il est le signe d'une
entière liberté mais sans les jamais
libre puisque on ne peut pas se voir
quand on veut on est obligé de mentir
tout le temps aux autres d'inventer des
scénarii pas peu celle là il ya eu
contrainte et
là il est vrai les oui mais justement le
alors on n'est peut-être pas l'hymne
mais on a quand même une sorte de
sentiment de liberté absolue puisque
quand on se retrouve ça n'est que pour
s'adonner à l'amour en quelque sorte
c'est ça et l'intensité et il ya cette
même jouissance dans le dans le vers
libre qui est dénué de contrainte c'est
à dire qu'on peut simplement faire de la
prose la coupe est arbitrairement à la
ligne et puis se réclamer du statut de
poètes
mais je trouve qu'il ya aussi une
véritable beauté dans là c'est pas du
tout un plaidoyer pour l'adultère seul
donc je me demandais d'ailleurs vous le
narrateur vous êtes de quel côté au fond
du mari ou de la manche pas je suis de
tous les côtés finalement je crois que
si j'ai de l'indulgence pour mes
personnages c'est par complaisance
envers moi même puisque certains de
leurs traits de caractère ont été
empruntés à ma propre personne que ce
soit du côté de la femme de la mort du
mari mais en les faisant on les
juxtaposant comme vous le faites dans
certaines parties du roman ils m'ont
très bien qu'il ya quelque chose
d'injuste au fond parce que si jean
beauty votre voiture
je vous dois des indemnités si je vous
la vole gier en prison si en revanche
vous vole votre femme et avec votre
femme vos enfants et peut-être même
votre maison puisque elle gardera les
enfants et la maison au fond je ne vous
dois rien il ne vous reste plus que dieu
pour pleurer mais au fond alors
volontairement ou involontairement vous
montrer ça vous montrer quelque chose
d'injuste au fond là-dedans ouais ça
il ya quelque chose d'injuste il ya
quelque chose de tragique
il ya quelque chose d'immensément
douloureux l'amour passionnel est en
amour qui 120 / on disait qu'un amour
qui s'en va est une série chez preuve
philosophique que d'un coiffeur elle
fait un émule de socrate et bien c'est
vrai que c'est une très riche y preuve
philosophique on passe par des ça peut
être pire qu'un deuil la fin d'un amour
c'est le deuil pour soi-même d'une
personne qui est encore en vie
que d'autres peuvent toucher
entendre sentir et pour vous allez elle
n'existe plus finalement vous n'y
avaient plus accès donc c'est quelque
chose qui peut être donc qui peut être
tout à fait tout à fait terrible et je
crois qu'il ya un basculement qui
s'opère dans la vie entre le moment où
on rails en quelque sorte les
souffrances du jeune werther est celui
où les ayant éprouvé on les fait siennes
on les comprend on les en dos et
et on ne prend plus le chagrin amoureux
la légère et c'est ça que j'ai voulu
essayer de montrer puisque cette
histoire est unique et est une fiction
en revanche
les sentiments que j'ai voulu restituer
je les ai évidemment éprouvé il serait
totalement oui comme nous tous c'est
tout à fait banal ce nouveau dans votre
histoire par rapport à d'autres romans
qui ont pu traiter de la même affaire
c'est le smartphone de smartphones c'est
la boîte noire des couples aujourd'hui
si vous accédez aux smartphones de votre
compagne votre compagnon vous savez à
peu près tranquille et atteint votre
couple vous savez c'est ce qui arrive
aux maris dans votre roman
mais pourquoi est ce que en l'occurrence
votre héroïne pourquoi il a tout gardé
pourquoi il n'a rien effacé à parce
qu'on a sans doute un désir justement de
consigner de consigner les l'histoire
que l'on vit est-ce que de se faire
découvrir ce qu de faire tout volé en
éclats et c'est lorsque orwell dans 1984
parle du télécran c'est à dire ceux
cet instrument de privation de nos
libertés qui est gouvernementale pour ce
têt l'écran finalement là aujourd'hui
notre poche et de notre plein gré toute
notre vie et consignés et quasiment
minute par minute
et pour autant on trouve ça tout à fait
normal oui mais on pourrait au moins
effacé ce qui risque de nous confondre
c'est vrai mais en douce que la morale
de votre roman pour moi c'est c'est tout
une question de tout est une question de
timing
vous appelez ça de queiros du moment
ouvrez le moment choisi au fond le le
moment de la rampe du moment de la
rencontre dépend l'histoire d'amour le
moment si elle avait rencontré l'âme en
avant le mari se serait peut-être
l'amant qui serait devenu le père de ses
enfants al'inverse sur le le le
en fait l'amour tient autant au moment
de la rencontre qu'à la personne que
vous rencontrez c'est aussi au c'est
aussi bête que ça
cc c'est une histoire de
de disponibilité sas attitude mon maître
et mon vainqueur ça vient de paraître
chez gallimard et c'est signé
françois-henri des érables c'est votre
vrai nom françois ruiz de mon vrai nom
récemment un prénom à mon vrai nom
[Musique]
le virement vous êtes artiste plasticien
mais vous êtes aussi le leader et le
parolier de musique post bourgeoise qui
sera nouvel ep sera en concert gratuit
jeudi à 23 heures aubin la célèbre boîte
de nuit parisienne vous aussi vous en
prenez autant d'ailleurs on écoute tout
de suite un extrait de kiss
le passé ne se promène jamais seul il
avance à courir du présent ils
poursuivent et l'enduit il épaissit
défilent j'avais pu ici le ramasse la
mise
ce n'est pas le futur qui tracte c'est
le passé qui
le passé un double des clés et sait où
et planck et le digestif et il va tout
[ __ ]
[Musique]
le passé
c'est de l'eau qui un soir
couper les réseaux grass et vos
immeubles allumez vos cartes de paiement
ont touché l'eau chaude claquettes si le
fou le passé arrive et il n'a pas
d'avenir d'autres ambitions que d'avancé
et est le cerveau reptilien
louette
arrachant nous avant qu'il nous arrache
tresson nous avant que nous dresse des
cages en gouvernant qui louent dégage
des ondes ou avant qu'une thèse oublions
le avant qu'ils effacent troublions nous
oublions
ce n'est pas le futur qui tracte c'est
le passé qui pousse c'est une bonne
formule bah c'est du vécu
c'est du vécu oui non mais quand on est
content on s'aperçoit qu'en fait tout ne
sera que du passé c'est à dire que nous
on développe des dd on a envie avec un
avenir mais pas seulement ça l'humanité
la terre elle-même alors là elle a une
durée de vie l'univers a une durée de
vie et tout d'ailleurs une autre oui
mais qui sera quand même englouti et son
nom il devrait ne plus rien y avoir à la
fin et tout devrait être engloutis par
par cette vague de passe et qui
finalement nous nous attrape nous la
tour où elle est là les sur nous ça fait
longtemps que je vous suis j'entends
musique post bourgeoise je crois que
vous n'avez jamais fait de textes sur
l'amour
il y en a mais je jeu il y en a un qui
est le cas de kate qui est que je fais
pas parce qu'en fait il est trop sais
pas si c'est vulgaire où il s'éteint
c'est un type qui veut en parler ce type
qui veut déclarer son amour à un homme
en l'occurrence femmes on est dans l'est
dans les poncifs mai et il a il le dit à
travers des textos il a un problème avec
son ballet de de chiottes qu'il a cassé
dans les toilettes et il en profite pour
déclarer des valeurs l'amour à travers
ce ces problèmes de balai cassé dans les
chiottes qu'il a il arrive pas nettoyé
normalement de l'amour c'est vraiment
c'est dans les premiers textes qu'on
écrit quand on écrit des textes pour les
primo les secondes et les effets quand
je vois la de 18 ans mais c'est assez
rare qu'en fait on fasse on commence à
faire une petite carrière musicale sans
jamais aborder lequel la question c'est
comment ça commence à se voir jacques
que j'apporte que des questions
existentielles en fait pas de plus dans
dans l'expérience de la vie que dans le
que dans le commentaire du sentiment la
musique post bourgeois lé c'est bonne
bande originale d'une société
hambourgeoise et malgré elle
c'est de lui dire que d'abord on et moi
je considère qu'on est tous bourgeois
parce qu'on consomme tous enfin la
nature de l'homme lé tout consommer la
première la première des choses c'est le
temps
je suis rendu compte que tout était du
temps uniquement on pourrait considérer
nos devis uniquement en addition d'heure
et cette émission a une durée elle a une
entrée à la une sortie c'est donc du
temps on pense qu'on fait une émission
mais on passe du temps de toute façon et
maintenant j'ai oublié la question c'est
est ce que est ce que d'autres sociétés
s'est embourgeoisé malgré l annonce et
ça c'est bon vous avez voulu vous lui
intimer quasiment l'ordre en tout cas
voulu conseillé d'en sortir demain c'est
énorme et c'est de se rendre compte
qu'en effet je pense que leur là je sais
pas si ce sont des domaines que je
maîtrise mois mais cette ce terme de
postes bourgeoise il est venu après un
incident à clochard en avait tué un
autre parce qu'il lui avait piqué son
carton sur lequel il dormait sous un
pont et je le suis dit qu'au fond la
poule la notion de propriété elle
démarrait même quand on n'avait rien et
que le par exemple j'étais assis sur un
coussin si c'était des clous je viens il
n'arrête pas un coussin on a envie
d'améliorer notre vie c'est dans la
nature en fête la bourgeoisie c'est de
l'hygiène c'est on a fait des savez vous
que nous avons passés faire un test ce
machin tout vide pour venir s'asseoir
ici savez-vous ça nous a mis un truc
dans le nez le savez vous
et donc la bourgeoisie c'est l'hygiène
ses deux pattes c'est cette propres pour
ne pas transmettre de maladies ou manger
ses demandes dormir proprement pour
éviter les punaises enfin c'est dans la
nature humaine l'embourgeoisement notre
humanité s'embourgeoise il est plus
question de ceux de se sentir en dehors
de ça on est bourgeois pascal jacob le
cirque aussi s'est embourgeoisé je ne
crois pas non
non ça reste vraiment un univers en
marge dans le bon sens du terme français
avec des érables bourgeois vous êtes
embauché moi ce que la littérature
il dit venait d'une famille de kaka y
est ce que 2 mais moi je suis écrivain
je gagne 10% par livre c'est vrai que
c'est bourgeois aisés en est un est-ce
que je suis à la recherche d'un certain
confort même jeu c'était c'était pas mal
de trucs à le coussin et les clous
effectivement mais il ya ces rousseau
disait que le plus le premier ayant
trouvé un terrain ayant mis des
barrières ayant clos le terrain fut le
vrai fondateur de la société civile
c'est le même idée c'est à dire cherche
à avoir une petite parcelle à nous mais
quand tu dis famille de quincaillerie
vous êtes tout le monde était
quincaillier d'uncarnée d'accord de
grand père en fils en est effectivement
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours et que
françois-henri des érables l'auteur de
mon maître raymond vainqueur avec pascal
jacob qui publie cloud et avec olivier
your man le leader du groupe musique
post bourgeoise qui sera nouvel ep et
sera en concert gratuit jeudi au bain à
23 heures
les paroles sont très fortes de musique
post bourgeoise et pas seulement parce
que vous les scandé
pour moi vous êtes un peu le dadaïsme
d'aujourd'hui malheureusement ça ressort
tout le temps j'aimerais bien être le
poste bourgeois d'aujourd'hui que le
dada east d'hier le nom d il se meut
doué mais
c'est insensé d'aller je trouve ça a un
sens c'est d'aller chercher un mouvement
artistique les santons et de saint louis
il ya une faiblesse parce qu'on leur
sort tout le temps donc c'est comme si
je faisais du tango jeu
non j'essaie d'être trop présent on va
écouter un autre extrait de cette paix
satie tulle les limites
je ne trouve pas de limite à l'ennui
je ne vois ni la sortie ni l'entrée
rien ne me sépare de ce team en lasse
des menaces
autour de moi tout est mou
les objets durs sont mous et les objets
nous sont encore plus
tous pour
tous mouche
tout ce pyrotechnique
se coiffe tous ceux jambes épilées tout
ce voyage en plein air ce comité
d'entreprise ce léchouiller se démoule
d'abbott
ce mâchonne tout ceci rod en terrasse ce
cri faune et se pomponne
tout m'effondre
tous ennuis tout ce cuisinier feu tous à
valmont
il n'y a rien sur quoi je puisse à dos
et mes épaules sans tomber dans l'oubli
rien sur quoi je puisse asseoir mon
fessier sont passés à la postérité
[Musique]
sur la route
la vitesse maximale d'une ferrari c 130
comme les twingo c'est la loi la loi ses
limites la loi à ses
hôtes en connaissez deux os en faire un
pour s'asseoir à l'arrêt
le père de la vence tout seul traîne en
retard tu se distance de freinage tu te
retrouves c'est ce recul pourrait qu'on
s'emmerde de plus en plus forme
on a oui c'est une faculté de pouvoir
s'emmerder de plus en plus fort c'est
lié à une culture personnelle c'est un
goût non parce qu'il arrive plein de
trucs on nous annonce la fin du monde et
ethernet c'était et c'est toujours la
même fin du monde enfin je veux dire
ça se répète donc plus on le comprend et
on s'emmerde parce que cette fin du
monde car ils vont alors allez encore
une fin du monde
souvent on dit qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
d'or sur la même musique que leurs
parents c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas inventé
grand chose depuis 25 ans il n'y a pas
de vraie rupture musicale peut être à
part vous voilà ça c'est beaucoup
d'honneur mais je peux mais alors
justement j'ai eu une j'ai eu une
conversation là dessus il semblerait que
la musique actuelle de soi plus chez
nous il serait en afrique centrale et
avec des mouvements alors que je n'ai
plus les jeunes et pas les noms mais
j'ai préféré c'est illusoire et dessus
dans la musique du xxème siècle une
sortie d'afrique oui bien nommé sauf
qu'elle était laide et et occidentalisée
saverne en effet tout ce qu'on connaît
de des groupes
afro africain
a été vendue par l'occident alors classe
à part directement grâce à internet de
de l'afrique et de des îles qu'arabes et
carabines des caraïbes et
et qu'il existe au point un énorme
marché mondial de la musique mais qui
nous échappent complètement que certains
connaissent s'y intéressent mais sa part
pas de chez nous est pour bat pour ce
qu'il est un bon merci pour la musique
pour ce qui est de la musique je fais
nous irait ce music prize
qui sera donc en concert choisir fin
sans embûche ou parce qu'il est présent
là assez séduit avec qui je fais des
musiques et il sera singh jeudi soir au
bain à 23 heures sinon le p s'intitule
limites la limite où elle a living
[Musique]
pascal jacob vous êtes directeur
artistique du cirque du phénix à paris
qui présente actuellement gaïa un show
acrobatique exécuté par quarante
artistes de sexe féminin et qui
accueille chaque année le festival
mondial du cirque de demain dont vous
êtes également le directeur artistique
et vous publiez clown une coédition
entre le seuil et la bnf d'ailleurs
sur l'histoire des clones depuis leur
origine le mot cloud dit vous êtes
employé depuis le 16e siècle alors quel
est son rôle dans le théâtre
élisabéthain et pourquoi est ce que le
clown à un moment quitte la scène du
théâtre pour se réfugier dans les foires
d'abord puis sur les pistes du cirque
bien plus tard alors son rôle son rôle
premier c'est la rupture en fait c'est
vraiment une espèce de liberté totale en
plein milieu de la tragédie ont fait
entrer le clown littéralement pour les
mêmes temps du shakespeare
dans les tout premiers dans les toutes
premières pièces oui et ensuite
shakespeare qui est comme beaucoup de
dramaturges de l'époque n'en pouvez plus
évidemment a obtenu que les clowns soit
intégrée dans la trame de la pièce on
aurait plupart des pièces de shakespeare
vous avez le rôle le cloud est un rôle
en fait et
et à partir de ce moment là évidemment
les clones s'amuse beaucoup moins ils
ont moins de liberté donc le plus
célèbre de tous quand va quitter la
scène élisabéthaine quitté la troupe de
shakespeare pour aller s'exprimer
s'épanouir en toute indépendance et
c'est lui qui va
planter ce germe du clown qui deviendra
le clown de piste et le clown de cirque
et au même moment au xvième siècle en
italie mia l'arlequin c'est ça la
commedia dell'arte c'est assez troublant
de voir que deux formes théâtrales sont
parfaitement contemporaine sont
parfaitement voisine s'ignorent
complètement évidemment et donc la
commedia dell'arte va survivre parce
qu'aujourd'hui si vous demandez à
n'importe qui de vous dessinez un motif
d'arlequin il va immédiatement l'idée va
jaillir alors que le théâtre
élisabéthain finalement le motif d'un
bloc a d'ailleurs il faut le rappeler
vous le faites dans votre livre ce sont
des rats pièce mans 1 absolument c'est
là la métaphore delà de l'avarice de son
patron en fait chaque fois qu'il ya un
trou l'on trouve un morceau d'étoffé on
complète alors après évidemment
l'arlequin romantique il est beaucoup
plus géométrique mais initialement label
harlequins c'est un arlequin
multicolores finalement et et en france
pas de cohue en france à ce moment là je
parle vous avez des farceurs des
farceurs qui
du put depuis le théâtre médiéval
consiste à
farcir réellement le mystère donc il est
l'incarnation là les volumes l'évocation
de la passion du christ et on on insère
on intègre en farsi en fait dans une
certaine mesure de moment parfaitement
iconoclaste ce parfois et donc ces
petits instants de rupture encore une
fois sont là l'essence la veine comique
que l'on peut trouver en france puis
ensuite c'est tout les ans tout puisque
yann pierrot aussi à la pyrrhus beaucoup
plus tardif mais les arts l'aller les
italiens vont venir en france les
italiens vont facile des molières ont
fasciné marivaux savait pas par hasard
si le personnage d'arlequin traverse
l'oeuvre de marivaux et molière molière
a vu évidemment les comédiens italiens
ils sont nés il s'en est nourri s'en est
inspirée et fayet une scène magnifique
de dans le molière de nous qui nous
ronge on voit le jeune
poclain de vendée des théâtres des
acteurs de tréteaux dans une rue qui
sont secteur italien et il a on voit
qu'il est il est bouleversé le pied on
dit aussi le jean baptiste oui bah parce
que c'est jean baptiste bureau parce que
évidemment là s'étaient sentis assez la
fiche des
illustrations sorte de votre livre cette
scène sublime évidemment de de jean
louis barrault incarnant jean baptiste
de bureaux sur sur la scène du tas des
funambules enfin c'est vraiment c'est un
moment un moment de beauté pure quoi
donc là on est dans les ports tommy main
on est dans la peta dans la pantomime
absolument parce que ça correspond à une
période où les et les acteurs certains
acteurs certains comédiens évidemment à
fortiori les les acrobates et certains
membres n'ont pas le droit de s'exprimer
s'est réservé quelques théâtres
privilégiez donc inévitablement il faut
trouver des subterfuges le mime en est
un l'utilisation domaine de nos bateaux
pf1 d'entre eux on trouve toutes sortes
de moyens pour continuer d'exprimer le
théâtre sans avoir recours à la parole
il ya jean baptiste dubois aussi dont
vous parlez qui est le clown du cirque
de philippe clay en 1780 le premier
cirque moderne au fond c'est ça
absolument et jean baptiste dubourg là
c'est vrai que l'histoire l'a un peu
oublié et on a tendance toujours
appréciable que vous avez retrouvé une
affiche voilà son nom y figure en tant
que cloud ne cessa absolument et c'est
semble-t-il la première fois qu'on
utilise ce mot là au cirque
puisqu'évidemment shakespeare là là
largement utilisé et c'est vrai que
l'histoire a été un peu avare avec jean
baptiste dubois on l'a on l'a un peu
zappé en fait on pense toujours à
grimaldi qui est un des années le grand
clown la figure clownesque d'origine
italienne mais qui toute sa carrière en
angleterre sauf qu'il n'a jamais mis les
pieds sur un épisode donc ya tom welling
ci qui crée le personnage d'auguste oui
ça c'est une histoire magnifique et que
ces histoires le cirque est nourri de
deux légendes de l'histoire merveilleuse
effectivement un type qui trébuche qui
s'étale qui fait rire parce qu'on est à
berlin parce qu'on a regroupé lien
berlinois idiot se dit auguste on
l'interpellent on le traite di dio est
en fait on le traite d'auguste et quand
il se relève et les transfigurer il est
devenu un autre un personnage mais dit
aussi que c'est lui qui va faire
valoir
enfin c'est lui qui va au fond
inciter à la compassion pour celui qui
tombe il est le premier aussi à se
déguiser en clochard au fond oui mais
parce que parce que le clown si on
devait être puriste le clown c'est le le
clown blanc donc at on envie de
s'identifier à ce clown qui finalement
aux commandes organise dirige alors que
l'auguste il trébuche il fait sourire il
il émeut donc c'est peut-être à lui
qu'on a envie de s'attacher davantage et
là je pense que la force du duo
clownesque elle vient de l'alien de ceux
de ce rapport de force ce personnage qui
qui en trébuchant un quart de l'humanité
tout entière mais il ya la figure de la
pauvreté aussi qui traverse à la foire
lequin qui traverse l'auguste
on a l'impression que ces inséparables
le clown est forcément faible
vulnérables et pauvres fragile
probablement fragile et effectivement
qui construit qui construit son rôle son
personnage et son comique à partir de
d'artifice minuscule et
l'internet la plus belle incarnation
évidemment c'est de chaplin le vagabond
le trump lobo qui va qui va inspirer
après la après la crise de 29 des
personnages notamment aux états unis qui
vont qui vont justement un carnet d des
vagabonds sur la piste jusque là on les
considérait comme dégradant pour l'image
du cirque après vingt-neuf parce que
c'est normal de voir des gens qui errent
qui ont tout perdu qui sont sur les sur
les routes d'amérique on considère
finalement qu'ils incarnent une partie
de la société et ses personnages comme
maîtres kelly comotto gribling vont vont
être d'une poésie absolument incroyable
et ils sont seuls leur clown blanc c'est
le public mais si on revient un peu
avant vous parler dès les premiers
clowns sont pour vous des athlètes du
rire mais au sens littéral on va voir on
va voir des images où effectivement on a
l'impression qu'ils sont ils surgissent
hibon dit si ça part dans tous les sens
les clowns oui parce que je ne vienne
siècle parce que le circuit physique
parce que le cirque et le répertoire le
vocabulaire s'écrit à partir de
l'acrobatie donc la maîtrise du corps et
que les clowns notamment les premiers
français on pensa à jean baptiste auriol
par exemple vous voulez vous les emmenez
un peu plus tard qui ne sont pas
français leur comique est basée
justement sur cette espèce de
déflagrations physique d'énergie pure
brut et et qu'il parsème de d'effets
comiques ou supposés comique parce
qu'elle donne il explose littéralement
la scène il explose même il se bat il se
fit les coups de hache excès passés ces
abcès mais les gens rient parce
qu'évidemment on est dans dans
l'irréalité la plus la plus totale et
oriol est un sauteur prodigieux et en
même temps il était vêtu comme un
bouffon et il
les mets de petits cris et les gens
sourient en le voyant alors qu'il est il
est capable de faire un saut périlleux
de tomber droit dans cette lancée avant
tout aux enfants la difficulté pour les
clowns ça va être de se rendre
indispensable parce qu'au départ sont
des faire valoir
c'est ça c'est ça il ya de mettre en
valeur les acrobates les lie à cette
ambiguïté en fait on pourrait penser que
l'acrobate et le surhomme et le monsieur
loyal et l'homme et le clown et
l'auguste sont les sous-hommes dans une
certaine dans une certaine dynamique ils
sont là effectivement pour dans leur
façon d'être contrefaits volontairement
ils sont là pour valoriser ce que de
l'acrobate incarne c'est à dire une
quasi perfection physique
est alors le comment est-ce qu'il va
prendre le pouvoir le kun est ce qu'il
lui faut un moment prendre le pouvoir
s'il ne veut pas être constamment le
faire valoir des autres bah en fait la
liste l'histoire est bien fait
l'auguste va s'affranchir de son clown
et va prendre le pouvoir seul l'image de
grock effectivement qui est un des tout
premiers à avoir abandonné son clown le
clown le clown blanc le ruban blanc son
partenaire autoritaire et et groc a
construit un numéro de 45 minutes donc
en fait ils avaient plus besoin de
personnes presque plus besoin d'autres
artistes et avec un partenaire très très
discret qui acceptaient inquiets a écrit
ses mémoires en dix ans j'étais l'ombre
d'un clown donc vraiment il avait il
avait accepté l'idée en frac très
discret et qui passaient les instruments
qui relançait le comique de grottes qui
d'un seul coup a pris un pouvoir absolu
sur et et sur son partenaire et sur le
plateau et sur le public on dit que le
duo entre le clown blanc et l'auguste au
fond c'est footy et chocolat qu'ils ont
inventées ou tournant du xxème siècle
celui - c'était une vraie bref c'est une
dualité très étranges ou fou titan fait
aperçus parce que chocolat en fait une
histoire un enfant d'esclaves qui s'est
échappée qui a été
arrivé avec un marchand à bilbao un
marchand espagnol et s'est trouvé engagé
par un premier clown anglais qui
l'engagé comme serviteur en fait comme
comme valet qui l'a amené à paris et
foot ide qui était à ce moment là
également à paris au nouveau cirque
s'est dit mais on peut pas laisser ce
garçon qui a une espèce de talent
naturel et il a pressenti que raphaël
padilla que chocolat pouvait aller bien
au delà que d'être simplement un valet
et ils ont forgé ce duo
impossible et en même temps et en même
temps une extraordinaire acuité avec
avec ce rapport de couleur de peau ce
rapport de forces aussi puisque foot it
maltraitait malmené chocolat mais que
dans certaines dans certaines petites
bandes dans certains petits films du
temps on voit que chocolat finalement
parfois prend prend ainsi sa revanche et
puis chocolat surtout à des noirs
célèbre on le voit qui donne des coups
de pieds au cap du morbier et chocolat
une gloire absolument incroyable
superstar c'est une super star pendant
quelques quelques années ça n'a pas duré
très longtemps pendant quelques années
il a été il a été vela il a incarné
vraiment le nouveau sirh celui qui sait
c'est de là que vient l'expression clown
blanc pour foot y ont leur clown blanc
parce qu'il est blanc et que chocolat
noir non le clown dans c'est vraiment la
mesure au maquillage si vous voulez le
premier c'était ce fils de l'inventeur
de la tragédie dans l'antiquité grecque
qui pour pour unifier son visage se
passe du blanc et ensuite on voit cette
cette manière de transformer de
transcender son visage on la retrouve
dans certaines figures de l'esprit des
morts dans théâtre médiéval c'est cette
idée de se recouvrir de blanc et de
structurer les lignes à nouveau avec du
un peu de noir un peu de rouge elle
traverse en fait toute l'histoire du
théâtre mais presque toute l'histoire
delà de la représentation et les clowns
naturellement après après de bureau et
avec deux bureaux vont vont profiter de
cette unification il ya un jean farine
aussi comme son nom l'indiqué qui sans
farine et le visage pour pour se
dissimuler en fait et et à carder autre
chose de sensible aux clowns france
quand les deux hommes
alors on n'en voit pas mal dans les
médias aussi nié aujourd'hui ils sont
invités sur les plateaux télé
et en général ils parlent de politique
vous le voyez je suis moins sensible je
suis plus sensible à ce devons parler
plutôt qu'à la si je viens d'évoquer
vous aimez les clous de virement à
priori comme ça non non je suis dérangé
oui c'est sans doute parce que moi même
j'ai une expression un peu clownesque
dents et je trésor limité c'est ça me
reflète un peu donc ça me dérangerait
sinon ils ont moins la cote les clowns
ils peuvent même faire peur aujourd'hui
stephen king s'en est servi à plusieurs
reprises il ya la couleur aux phobies
qui était en fait qui est maintenant de
donner un nom sur la terreur face aux
clowns donc c'est devenu presque une
pathologie d'avoir peur des clous et il
ya eu des peintres qui ont abusé aussi
faut bien reconnaître ouais mais qu'ils
sont magnifiés aussi parce que même le
mais même les formes les plus sombres je
pense à aru ses tableaux sont absolument
mais drouot sava buffet c'est un peu
moins oui il ya une baie en même temps
il ya une espèce de est une grandeur du
personnage qui est où est ce qu'ils en
sont les clowns aujourd'hui oui ce
qu'ils en sont où est-ce qu'elles en
sont parce que je crois que quand il ya
des phares effectivement j'ai pas il ya
des femmes c'est je pense que l'avenir
du cloud c'est la femme c'est la femme
ouais il ya de plus en plus de deux
femmes que moi j'ai bien le mot cloud 2
avec 1 m/s plutôt que clooney sous femme
clown mais oui il ya une une vraie assez
bonne forme non c'est pas un courant
c'est carrément yens il ya
les femmes prennent leurs parties
dansées votre livre il y en a une c'est
pas cette photo là c est la suivante
mais elle a pas 50 1 en photo dans le
livre j'en ai trouvé une part il a fallu
faire des choix mais on a été très très
malheureux évidemment mais il y en a
beaucoup on a beaucoup à dell notamment
mais roselyne guinée va à pied puis je
pense puis évidemment annie fratellini
qui a marqué qui a marqué son temps et
et au delà de son temps et on évoqué
tout à l'heure le théâtre ariane
mnouchkine qui a créé le spectacle est
clown ou si vous avez des dons aux
femmes sur scène mais ce que j'entendais
à part si l'on met à part le fait qu'il
ya des femmes aujourd'hui est ce que
l'art du clown a changé et ce qu'ils
évoluent ils évoluent il retrouve
probablement ses racines politiques
c'est à dire que tout à l'heure on est
vraiment des veaux créant les les clones
politique mais à une époque les clowns
s'inspirait véritablement de la
politique au sens de du quotidien de
gérer la ville pour pour écrire leurs
saynètes ya un clown
soviétique car ans d'âge qui est crayon
à russe qui chaque jour dans le journal
notait des faits des faits marquants et
les restituer sur la piste
avec puis on a vanté au fond le métier
de chansonniers une sorte de satire
effectivement fibre là vous avez là une
image absolument magnifique ça vous avez
arletty et puis et puis vous avez on
voit pas sa tête mais c'est patrice
chéreau patrice chéreau qui donne une
classe une master class avec des clowns
et ça je pense que c'est c'est un moment
absolument incroyable mais obilale des
femmes clown y en a énormément aidés et
des femmes clown qui équipe sa propre
qui s'approprie évidemment le personnage
pour aller vers une dimension plus
sociale plus proche de nous je pense que
c'est une dimension tout à fait
contemporaine il ya vous parliez de
chaplin c'est pas le seul qui a importé
au cinéma
la clownerie non mais là il en il en est
probablement un des précurseurs mais
laurel et hardy mais aujourd'hui alors
on admire c'est facile de dire que tout
est dans tout mais
astérix obélix c'est un duo clownesque
tintin et le capitaine haddock
évidemment et puis dans des séries
américaines moi j'ai frappé par la série
rome sur la chaîne et de bureaux avec
les deux les deux soldats les deux les
deux légionnaires romains y en a
clairement un qui le l'auguste de
l'autre face et il ya vraiment cette
cette dualité qui parcourt complètement
complètement notre histoire et notre
mais on a toujours l'impression que le
l'art du clown stannard muet on a tort
on a tort et on a raison parce que
effectivement on passe beaucoup par le
par l'expression l'expressivité mais que
à partir de 1874 à l'appart à partir du
moment où le la fin du conte empirer la
la fin des lois sur les privilèges
la parole circule et les clowns sont
emparés à partir de ce moment là la
parole est aussi un moyen d'expression
ça n'est pas forcément le seul je pense
à penser à un club comme david shiner
notamment qui n'a jamais utilisé le mot
ou un clown comme seul seul marc favreau
qui lui était un clown parleur mais il
fut un temps au xxème siècle ou des
clowns étaient d'immenses stars ont
parlé de grock tout à l'heure on
pourrait dire en france h et avatar oui
les fratellini les fratellini c'était
vraiment des très très grande star y en
a encore sa l'impression que ça ait
disparu on a probablement le j'imagine
que la notion de vedettariat pour un à
elle plutôt aller vers les acteurs
comiques ou ceux qui en tous les cas un
moment donné de leur carrière ont font
ce choix là c'est vrai que
le cirque véhicule d'une tradition
d'humilité que peut-être effectivement
que les fratellini grog grimaldi aussi
en son temps ont été hantées finalement
d'aider des étoiles filantes danser dans
cet univers le cirque à fabriquer des
stars dans tous les domaines des
acrobates
ou plutôt moins que dans d'autres formes
effectivement il ya eu quelques quelques
quelques artistes extraordinaires comme
lila downs elle par exemple la numéro
dano aujourd'hui on a du mal à y croire
mais cette femme qui faisait c'était de
toute petite taille kg en amener dans
ses bras sur la piste dans un chapiteau
à trois pistes américains dont vous
imaginez ce que ça signifie avec 10000
spectateurs tout seul minuscules
silhouettes qui montait au fait du
chapiteau dans avec des anneaux de
simples aux anneaux a pas de simples des
anneaux de gym et elle faisait un numéro
et la salle était bouleversé deux bouts
à la fin quoi ça a été ça a été une
immense star sur une numéro dont on
qu'on ne voit pratiquement plus jamais
aujourd'hui donc effectivement il ya eu
il ya quelques personnages rastelli
évidemment le jongleur phénoménal mais
ils éclosent dans dans ce petit panthéon
circassiens je pense que les clones
occupe la première place ce sont les
américains qui ont inventé le cirque
itinérant
non les américains ont inventé le
chapiteau donc il ya contribué à
accentuer le phénomène d'itinérance mais
en fait le cirque il est né dans la
pierre dans des bains pendant presque un
siècle comme le cirque d'hiver à paris
tout à fait comme pendant presque un
siècle en europe les troupes voyager
d'un bâtiment à l'autre donc un peu
comme des troupes de comédiens qui
allait d'un théâtre à l'autre et les
américains ont simplifié la vie du
voyage on a recréé dans une salle
autonome qui permettait une très grande
liberté d'installation d'implantation
donc le cirque tzigane tel qu'on se
l'imaginent prédécesseur du cirque
héritier du cirque américain non c'est
le contraire au fond les américains ont
ramené cette mobilité la l'hypermobilité
oui absolument les américains nous
amener ça et
et ensuite l'europe a vraiment suivi
sans forcément toujours copier mais on a
gardé cette
finalement cette liberté totale de
pouvoir s'implanter n'importe où
allaient les premiers chapitres
américain en fait c'étaient des ballots
de toile ont coupé un arbre n'importe où
on n'a rien on n'a même pas besoin de
transporter le mât on couper l'arbre on
mettait en planter l'arbre on installer
la toile et on avait un chapiteau donc
donc c'est une liberté incroyable qui je
trouve colle bien à l'imaginaire du
cirque à l'imaginaire des clones est ce
qu'il ya eu des grands clowns américains
parce qu'on a l'impression que tous ceux
qui sont restés tout ce dont on se
souvient c'est toujours des européens
des revenus beaucoup alors les italiens
ouais alors vous avez vous avez un clown
qui a même eu la gloire d'avoir un
timbre à son effigie logicoop ce qu'ils
étaient un allemand qui s'est installé
très tôt aux états unis qui est devenu
vraiment une figure emblématique et puis
les deux j'évoquais tout à l'heure et m
kelly et auto ghibli qui étaient plus
des trempes donc le vraiment le avec le
mal rasé etc
et quelques autres mais effectivement le
les grands noms qui nous viennent à
l'esprit sont plutôt européen le livre
s'intitule cloud il est paru donc au
seuil en coédition avec la bibliothèque
nationale de france j'imagine que c'est
pour les illustrations absolument et on
a puisé vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
la bnf les trésors de nos salles de
france et à 14 km de rayon sur les arts
vivants donc le siècle occupe la 14ème
14 kilomètres de là il ya énormément de
choses absolument formidable donc merci
vraiment à la bnf de permettre de
partager ses trésors merci tous les
trois d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]